-You know our next guest
for his work on
"Gossip Girl" and "Easy A."
He returns to star in
the fourth season of "You."
Part 1 begins
streaming globally
on Netflix February 9th.
Let's take a look.
-Whose coat is this?
-Easy does it.
Time to get this one home.
Couch, couch, couch.
-Malcolm got me home.
Do I need to thank him? No.
If I'm rude, maybe the
misogynist with a drug problem
will leave me alone.
New day.
No more craziness.
Back to the quiet.
[ Ominous music plays ]
-Please welcome to the show,
Penn Badgley, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I'm so happy to have you here!
-Yo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, I think this is
the first studio audience
since like, 2020, since COVID.
-Is it jarring to be back in
front of human beings like this?
-I mean, well, like this,
it's always jarring.
-Right, right, yeah.
-It's not --
-It's not a natural
state of things.
-Yeah, it's nothing on you.
All on me.
-This is a show, as evidenced by
the reaction when you came out,
with a very devoted fanbase,
but also, you play
a very terrible person.
-Yeah.
-Is that confounding to you,
that this is where people
are like,
"We love watching Penn do this."
-I mean...
So, yes, I mean,
I somewhat famously played
a cultural ref back when
it first came out,
and I was like, you know,
"He's a murderer!"
But I think now I'm just like,
that's also on us a bit.
We designed him.
-We're drawn to it.
-We designed him that way.
But it's, yeah, man.
I feel like I have
a front row seat
to this particular kind of...
that thing, you know?
The obsession thing,
and so, you know,
I bear witness and it's cool.
-There's some pretty gnarly
scenes in the show.
I would imagine it gets pretty
gross with the special effects.
-Yeah.
-Are there times where
you have to take a minute?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm not precious about
my process in any way,
but there have been a few times
where I've spontaneously
become nauseous.
Just in this last season --
when you don't finish a scene
on time in the day,
you have to go back
and do pick-ups,
and so I was in the middle
of something else.
I'm like, "Yeah, we're gonna go
do pick-ups for this scene
from the second episode
or first episode.
Sure, yeah, yeah."
And then I got to strap on
this jumpsuit,
and then I'm like, "Oh, right."
And then they spray me down
with blood, like,
fully, fully.
I have goggles on
and I'm just like,
"Okay, alright."
And then I walk into
this room they've created
to make it look like the place
we were in,
and it's full of smoke
and dark, fake blood
all over a table,
and a table saw with meat on it.
[ Crowd groans ]
-Yeah, that's -- yeah.
And, um, and I remember just
being like -- [Shudders]
It's not, um --
Your nervous system is
just like, "No!"
-Yeah, right.
And I would imagine, too,
when you're like,
"Alright, now what's this
character thinking?"
that's not a nice place
to go, either.
-Well, you know what's nice
is that
he's meant to be --
he's your likeable
serial killer.
He's your clumsy, like,
killer next door.
-He's a little, bumbling --
-So I just let the nausea
come through.
-Now, obviously, this was
a highly anticipated season,
and this was the art that you
put on social media.
But I've heard -- well,
you actually shared
after you posted it.
-I did.
-You had posted it maybe
before you were allowed.
-Yeah, before the embargo
was lifted.
Which makes it feel like
I'm an ambassador or something.
Like, "embargo."
-But a Netflix embargo,
I would imagine
that's a real deal.
-It is, yeah.
To be honest, I don't post much
on social media.
My batting average is high,
but I do not actually post.
I do not actually
post that much.
-It's very good to wait for
a big announcement like that.
-And even there had been
bigger announcements
about this season.
I hadn't posted.
But I just thought,
"You know what?
I'll do it this morning."
And I had a lot to do with my
son, and I was just like,
"If I don't do it now,
I'm not gonna do it."
It was 9:00 in the morning.
And I went to this, like,
there's this secret spreadsheet
from Netflix.
It's very confidential.
It made me quite nervous,
actually,
and I second-guessed it,
but then I found it.
It was all very complicated.
And I posted.
-As a fellow performer,
if I look at a spreadsheet,
I also get very nervous.
-Yeah, it's just --
-A lot of
the spreadsheet stuff in school
was not my forte.
-But I posted,
And I'm posting it on Instagram
and I'm thinking,
"What's a cute caption?
'Felt cute might delete.'"
[ Laughter ]
And I felt cute about that.
-You were being honest.
-Yeah, no. I felt cute,
and I had no intention
of deleting it.
-Yeah.
-And then I go back
to the spreadsheet --
why, I don't know --
and it says,
"Do not post until noon."
And I was like...
I mean, it's 9:00.
[ Laughter ]
Is that a big deal? Three hours?
Like, does that matter?
And I'm thinking to myself,
like,
"Okay, who cares? Should I?"
But then I was like,
"No, I'm gonna..."
And I deleted it,
and then I realized...
...I felt cute and I deleted it.
-Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
-And then -- no, and then --
So at this point,
the post doesn't exist
except to the few, I don't know,
100 or maybe 1,000 people
who saw it,
and I thought,
"That was brilliant."
-Yeah!
-To them, the few!
And then I thought,
"Do I leave it like that
or do I follow through
and post the post
that I was gonna post because
I'm trying to be a team player?"
And so then I posted it,
and believe it or not,
I posted all of this
in a caption.
-Yeah.
What you just told us.
-I might have told the story
better in that caption.
So you can go check.
-You know, if your phone
has the megabytes
to download the whole post.
It's a really cool show.
Thank you so much
for being here.
We really appreciate it.
You guys, that's Penn Badgley!
The first part of
Season 4 of "You"
begins streaming today
on Netflix.
We'll be right back
with "Late Night."